hello ladies and germs boys and girls
lemurs and squirrels all things
under the sun this is tim ferriss
welcome to another episode of the tim
ferriss show
where it is my job to deconstruct
world-class performers people who are
excellent world-class
at what they do to tease out all sorts
of things frameworks
questions they ask favorite books
influences you name it lessons learned
my guest today is texas native matthew
mcconaughey he is one of hollywood's
most sought after
leading men a chance meeting in austin
long ago with casting director and
producer don phillips
led him to director richard linklater
who launched the actor's career in the
cult classic dazed and confused
since then he has won an academy award
for his portrayal of
ron woodruff in dallas buyers club
appeared in more than 40
feature films that have grossed more
than one billion dollars and has become
a producer director and philanthropist
with his just keep live in foundation
all the while sticking to his texas
roots and jk live in philosophy
mcconaughey also serves as creative
director for wild turkey
and has co-created his own bourbon long
branch he serves as minister of culture
moc for the university of texas athletic
department
in the austin fc soccer club where he is
part owner
mcconaughey will launch his first book
green lights on october 20th
2020. he currently resides in austin
texas with his wife camilla and their
three kids while he is a professor at
the university of texas
in austin you can find them on facebook
matthew mcconaughey
on instagram officially mcconaughey and
on twitter
at mcconaughey the book's official
website is greenlights.com
please enjoy this wide-ranging extremely
enjoyable and entertaining conversation
with none other than
matthew mcconaughey
this podcast episode is brought to you
by helix sleep
sleep is super important to me in the
last few years i've come to conclude it
is the end-all be-all
that all good things good mood good
performance good everything
seem to stem from good sleep so i've
tried a lot
to optimize and i've tried pills and
potions
all sorts of different mattresses you
name it and for the last few years i've
been sleeping on a helix
midnight luxe mattress i also have one
in the guest bedroom
and feedback from friends has always
been fantastic it's something that they
comment on
helix sleep has a quiz it takes about
two minutes to complete that matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and every
body that is your body also your taste
so let's say you sleep on your side
in like a super soft bed no problem or
if you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress
that's as firm as a rock they've got a
mattress for you too helix was selected
as the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
magazine
wired apartment therapy and many others
just go to helixsleep.com
tim take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10-year
warranty
and you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up from
you if you don't love it and now my dear
listeners helix is offering up to 200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows
at helixsleep.com tim these are not
cheap pillows either so getting two for
free
is an upgraded deal so that's up to 200
off and two free pillows at
helixsleep.com
tim that's l helix x
sleep.com tim for up to two hundred
dollars off
so check it out one more time helix
h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com tim
this episode is brought to you by magic
spoon magic spoon is a brand new cereal
that i eat just about every day that is
low carb high protein and zero
sugar i just ate a huge bowl of their
cocoa flavor
about an hour ago after a short workout
magic spoon cereal
has received a lot of attention since
launching last year
time magazine included it in their list
of best inventions of 2019
and forbes called it the future of
cereal it tastes just like your favorite
sugary cereal from childhood remember
that
but it's actually good for you each
serving has 11 grams of protein
3 grams of net carbs 0 grams of sugar
and only
110 calories it's also gluten free grain
free keto friendly soy free and
gmo free all the things it's delicious
and i don't say that lightly because
most of this healthy
version of x stuff is not delicious but
these guys really nail it magic spoon
has nailed it it comes in your favorite
traditional cereal flavors like cocoa
frosted and blueberry you can try them
all by grabbing a variety pack
at magicspoon.comtim or you can just
grab a box
or a bunch of boxes i'm going to order
some more today of the coco which is my
personal favorite but there is a new
contender for favorite flavor because
they just
launched two limited edition flavors
honey nut and peanut butter which are
delicious i am a sucker for peanut
butter
and it is outstanding so i think cocoa
and peanut butter are my two new
favorite flavors and fun fact
my friends are also obsessed with magic
spoon one of the podcasts
most popular guest dr peter tia
routinely crushes six to seven servings
at a time that's a lot
with no glycemic response he's looked at
this with a glucometer
he likes it so much he invested other
friends two
very fine gentlemen and also past
podcast guests kevin rose and ryan
holiday
also invested so check it out see what
the buzz is about go to magicspoon.com
tim and grab a variety pack or coco
which is my favorite or anything else
but
see what strikes your fancy why not try
a variety pack
and be sure to use code tim at checkout
my listeners that's you
get free shipping and a 100 happiness
guarantee so if you're not a fan if you
don't love it they'll give you a full
refund no questions
asked again check it out magicspoon.com
forward slash tim that's magicspoon.com
forward slash tim
take a look optimal at this altitude i
can run flat out for a half mile before
my hands start to shake
can i answer your personal questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissues
[Music]
matthew welcome to the show good to be
here tim
how are you sir i'm doing very well and
i have just an embarrassment of riches
in front of me in terms of notes
that i would love to to take some stab
at covering even a portion of
and i thought we could begin with a
little back story for those people who
know your work but perhaps not your
personal story
let's paint a picture of your parents
now i was
in preparation for this conversation
doing some homework and i came across
a quote of yours feel free to fact check
this of course this is from the guardian
but it says
one of the great images i have of my
father is on the phone with a cigarette
at the airport on the pay phone always
peddling
what was he peddling pipe and how
pipe what is what is that for those who
don't know piping couplings so even
in the oil business and to drill you
obviously pipe and the couplings are
what connect the pipe
to drill for oil so dad was in the pipe
and coupling business and he was
he would call it peddling pipe peddling
pipe
and that's what he did on the phone
eight to six and then he'd hit the road
and go make personal appearances trying
to sell pipe he started off as a
truck driver then owned a texaco station
down in uvalde
we moved to longview texas in the oil
boom and within like six months after
being in longview
dad had like 26 employees under him
that's how
big of an oil boom it was and then
obviously that business fell through
i think around 82 and he kind of held on
from there
he was always a pebble always peddler
his line was great he was always because
he never did it he never went bankrupt
and that was a
piece of honor for him not to go
bankrupt but
he was always after the old boom sort of
busted he was always like boys if i
could just
hit a lick oh if i could just hit a lick
and he never did hit that lick um but if
if he
is a lick is that a big cell a lick is a
big account a lick is
okay mr jim mcconaughey i want all my
pipe from you and we're gonna drill
two hundred thousand feet so it's a huge
account oh my gosh
i'm gonna supply all the pipe to this
one large account that would be a lick
he never quite hit it
so we're going to jump to the other
track with mom for a second here
and i'd like to have a conversation
about
or description maybe of mink oil i would
like to
could you can you tell us how how mink
oil entered your life please
yeah i would not be here talking to you
right now if it wasn't for the
oil of me yeah
i think it was about how old was i 14
15 years old ninth grade adolescence
my mom starts pedaling again peddling my
whole family was peddling something
my mom starts peddling this oil of meat
product um
door-to-door sales look here you you put
this
mink oil on your face and it brings out
all the impurities that you have and
once those impurities all come out you
then have clear glowing skin for the
rest of your life
that was sort of the sales pitch right
well i'm 15. i got a few pimples as any
15 year old does and one night my mom
goes well
you should choose this all of me i'm
like great geez
you let me do that sure so i start
putting this oil and mink on my face
every night before i go to bed and after
about a week
i wake up and i've got more pimples than
i had a week before
and i i check in the mirror and go to
mom as the storm she goes
oh that's exactly what it's supposed to
do pull out all the impurities
keep doing it stick with it sure man so
i just religiously keep putting it on
well after two weeks now i seem to be
running into a problem here i've got
i've got a whole face full of pimples
and it's it's it's getting
pretty severe and i go back tomorrow
she's like oh wow well you've just got
more impurities than i thought you'd
have just keep keep doing it we're going
to
keep bringing out those impurities i
keep it up three weeks go by and now
i've got full blown acne
and i'm really concerned and my mom's
just staying on with it going wow no
stick with it all the impurities are
coming out well i sneak off to a
dermatologist
on my own and this was not my mom's
recommendation
i sneak out there on my own and i take a
bottle of this meat call with me and i
go doc look at my face this he goes what
are you putting on your face and i show
him this body
he reads the label he's like oh no no no
no no no no
this is for someone that's like 40 or
older not a teenage
child who's got oily pores anyway this
is blocking your pores your pores can't
breathe
you are 10 days away from having ice
pick
holes in your face from the acne we've
got to get you off of this
okay because we also have to get you on
this stuff called accutane it's a year's
worth of uh
medicine it will dry you up there will
have its complications but it'll be
better than
in the acting that you can have so boom
i get on the accutane
off the oil of me and around that time
my dad who was always as i said peddling
and looking how to hit a lick
looks at me he says damn boy i
i think we got a lawsuit against this
company
damn well i'm being comfortable i mean
you're a good-looking son i mean look at
you you're all swole up so he
he takes me to see his lawyer i remember
his name with jerry harris so
i'm sitting down with my dad and his
lawyer jerry harris and i think we got a
case and
he asked me like you know hey did your
confidence lower
you know with these uh with these
pimples you've got this acne going back
well yes sir i mean
are you doing as good with the girls i
said no sir not at all he
his eyes light up and i can tell that
even at my age at 15 that he
he's building his case and he goes
emotional distress
you were under emotion you are under
emotional distress and i look at him and
i'm like
uh sure yeah emotional distress and
jerry's
gosh dawg we can get 35 to 50 000 off
emotional distress would go a long way
jim
and my dad's like hot damn that tit
that's right fifty thousand dollars
let's way to go son
and so dad's getting all excited about
this deal we're gonna make fifty
thousand dollars off of my emotional
distress
his youngest son so anyway meanwhile i'm
on accutane
and everything takes a year to get clear
up and you get
scaly you're dandruff and your knees
hurt and you get slits in your
mouth and everything else but much
better than this acne and this
acutane starts clearing this acne up on
my face
well as lawsuits go you know they they
drag on a while
so come two years later i'm back
in jerry harris law office sitting
across the table from
the from the defense attorney and now
my acne is cleared up okay and
this lawyer sits here and starts off the
conversation with me and he goes
oh my gosh it must have been so
emotionally distressful
and i'm like he's lobbing me a softball
here i'm going to knock this out of the
park
yes sir it was highly emotionally
stressful and he's like i bet your
confidence was down i was like
he did it again what's this guy doing
he's a horrible lawyer he's teeing me up
we're just
knocking out the park again i guess it
was so emotionally distressful my
confidence was slow
wasn't doing well with the girls i mean
man it was bad stuff sir
and i'm sitting there thinking we've got
this case
well this little volkswa boy gets this
cheshire grin on his face reaches
under the desk and pulls out this green
yearbook
and it's got a page marked on it
and he opens it over in front of me
turns it around and opens it to a
specific
specific earmark page and points to a
picture
now this was the 1988
yearbook for longview high school which
now i was a senior
and mind you this lawsuit started back
when i was a sophomore
in this picture my senior year
he points to it and said who's that and
there's a picture of
camisa springs really beautiful lady
girl 18 year old with a sash across her
chest that says
most beautiful well arm in arm with her
and next to her
is the other named matthew mcconaughey
with the sash
off his chest that says most handsome
[Laughter]
as soon as i see that i squint my eyes
i'm like oh we just lost the case i look
up at him
the boy smiles and he goes so
emotionally distressful
right then we had lost the case and it
was over
and i remember my dad him and hauled for
for months gosh
dammy boy i mean we were gonna win 50
000 and you got to go off and win most
handsome you screwed up the whole deal
man
oil of mink and and the mcconaugheys who
chased litigations but never quite went
them that was another way of my dad
trying to hit a lick
and uh i screwed it up by one of most
handsome
was it true in your family i read this
of course you can't believe everything
that you read
two things number one that your parents
were divorced twice married three times
so they ended up getting up one more
time then they got knocked down
yeah true number two that
saying i can't was forbidden or
highly advised against very heavily
heavily heavily
i remember cuss word you could say
[ __ ] and [ __ ] and damn and even
occasionally
maybe get away with the lord's name in
vain but you weren't really
that was on the line but the real words
that we got like
either punished for or were forbidden
were
hate and can't and
i remember my dad i remember one
saturday morning when when i was
about 12 my saturday morning chores were
you know mow the lawn weed
shine his shoes and sweep the porches
and get the cobwebs out of the corners
well i'd get up very early on a saturday
morning to do that so i could have my
saturday afternoon to play
and i went out to try and start our push
uh lawnmower
and it wouldn't start pull again
wouldn't start pull again wouldn't start
check the gas yet it's got gas what the
heck is going on damn it won't start
i remember going into my dad inside and
i go dad the uh
uh i can't get the lawnmower started and
he kind of slowly turned his head to me
and i saw his molars meet
and kind of start to grit his teeth and
he goes you what
and i knew enough right then to not
say the word again and i said i i i
i and he got up and i didn't finish my
ascent
he slowly walked with me out of his
bedroom through the kitchen through the
garage around the back to the shed where
this lawnmower
was that uh i was not getting started he
without seeing a word he
knelt down looked at it checked the gas
but anyway he found
the little tube there where the gas was
not transferring and it had been
disconnected so they
so he reconnected that pulled a few
times and it started
and there over a new now running push
lawnmower
he looked at me put his hands on my
shoulders and for the first time since i
said i
can't get it started he put his hands on
my shoulders looked at me and very
sternly said he goes
you see something you were just having
trouble
from this lawnmower and boom
you know and i remember from that day i
was that lesson was like oh
even if you're unable to do something on
your own
you can still go seek help or get
assistance
so you're still only having trouble even
if you on your own cannot do so
that was a say in those words still to
this day if i let them slip i kind of
have to look over my shoulder like oh
dad gonna get me
[Laughter]
so there are many different forms of
influences i'd like to
ask you about one that is
not your parents it's not your siblings
it's a book
that i've read you came across that had
an impact
in your life and that is the greatest
salesman in the world by augmentino
could you explain for people listening
why that book was impactful or what
impact it had
both yeah so i've never been a big
reader
and growing up didn't read much and
never really
liked even in school being told hey you
got to read this book you got to read
this just the fact of being told i had
to read something in school or by
someone else
sort of made it feel like it wasn't mine
and i was not going to have a subjective
view of it and plus i just don't like
being told what to do
but this came to me this book and i
always say this i didn't find it it
found me and i'll tell you how and why
it was between my sophomore and junior
year in college at university of texas
at austin
now at this point i was always on the
track to become
a lawyer i was going to become that
defense attorney i was going to become
that defense attorney you know get us
some oil and make money
you know what i mean get the families
from all of make money
i was a good behavior i took good
stances it started off in the family
they're like geez oh man you know i
would take the table and win arguments
with the family and they'd be like
damn you got to become a lawyer you got
to become the family lawyer so that was
always the plan
well between my sophomore and junior
year and college
which is about the time when all those
general liberal arts
credits that you're getting need to have
start having some focus
or you're going to lose them you know
what i mean right so
i'm start not sleeping well with the
idea becoming a lawyer
i'm doing the math i'm like i'm not sure
it's what i want to do i get out of here
i go to law school then i get out then
i'd start maybe get an intern i'm really
not going to be
rolling in my vocation until i'm in my
30s and i was like do i don't really
want to spend my 20s
just learning or so my 20s just in
school
now i had been writing a lot i've been
keeping a lot of short stories in my
diaries and a lot of them
which are in this in this book green
lights but i didn't have the confidence
to think that maybe i wanted to get in
the storytelling business
until a good friend of mine rob bendler
who i think at the time was nyu film
school who i've been sharing some of
these short stories with
you know one night on the phone goes hey
you should think about
you know getting in front or behind the
camera you know you tell great stories
you got good character yourself
you know you're a good writer to try
this out and i was always like oh no no
no i don't i mean
that's that's like two avant-garde it's
too european it's
the artsy that i can't do that but he
gave me the confidence to really
consider it
now i go to
my fraternity house the dell house into
that sophomore year for sophomore exams
i'm a studier all right i'm making i got
a 3.82 gpa i'm i i
i like making my a's and any amount of
time i've got to study
i will use it every single minute
there's never
enough time for me to study i go to the
dell house
and right behind it in a little bungalow
is one of my adult brothers and i i
eat lunch and i sit on his couch and
i've got three hours before my exam
and i open up my books studying for my
psychology exam
for whatever reason for the first time
in my life i shut them and i go
mcconaughey to myself i go you got this
you don't need to study anymore first
time i've done that i got three hours to
kill i've been put on the tv
i love sports espn i'll watch cricket
the strongest man competition
i'll watch you know two grasshoppers
race
for whatever reason i just i'm not
interested i turn off the tv
i look over to my left there's a stack
of magazines there's sports illustrated
some playboys and i'm like
jeez i like sports i like checking out
naked ladies in the play boy let's check
that out
i pick up a playboy flipped their thumb
through that half agility and all of a
sudden lose interest in that
and i'm sitting okay what am i supposed
to do here
i got two and a half about three hours
to kill well i start
peeling back those magazines playboys
and sports illustrators and everything
else
and about seven deep in that stack of
magazines to the left of the couch where
i was
i see this white paperback with this
beautiful red cursive writing on it and
it says the greatest salesman in the
world
and i remember reaching for it and
allowed to myself saying
who is that and i pick up the book
and i start reading it again i'm not i'm
not a reader but i start reading this
book
and all of a sudden i lose track of time
and i've gotten past the whole prologue
to the beginning of this first scroll in
this book
which is i will form good habits and
become their slave now what this book
had just told me it just taken me on a
journey and said
you will read each scroll there's 10
scrolls in this book each scroll
three times a day for 30 days until you
move on to the next scroll
so it's basically a 10 month read
and i had gotten to the first scroll and
had been
now understood i now understood that the
greatest salesman in the world
was whoever's gonna read that book so i
was like oh that's me
he's talking to me well bam i look up
oh my exam's in 15 minutes i got to go
right head out
go to my exam my psychology exam i
ripped through that exam
i didn't care if i failed it i something
in this book had told me no this book
is what you need to be into right now
this book is going to give you
confidence to go do what you need to do
i rip through that psychology exam and
immediately go i'm going to film school
i'm calling dad tonight i'm not going to
go to law school anymore i've got the
confidence this book found me
this is a seminal moment in my life i
don't know how or why but it is
and i'm going to get the courage to call
my dad and go
and that night i uh
remember thinking about it i'm gonna
call my dad at 7 30. he'll have sat down
maybe at his first cocktail already had
dinner
and he'll be in a good mood for me to
say you know dad i want to go to film
school i think
well i call him 7 36 p.m
hey dad hey what's up son listen i i
don't
really and i was nervous and i said i
don't think i want to go to law school
anymore
i want to go to film school that was
hard for me to say because i thought he
was going to go you want to do
what boy what the hell papa i said
i don't know i'm going to go to film
school it was long pause on the phone
about five seconds
and he says you sure that's what you
want to do son
i said yes sir there's another five
second pause
and then he said three of the greatest
words i've ever been told
don't half-ass it
i remember going huh don't half-ass it
and i remember my eyes just
i lit up and i was like oh my gosh one
my dad
not only approved he gave me a
responsibility he gave me freedom he
gave me more than a privilege he like
sent me a flight and
ending it with like not only do i agree
and say that's okay son
i'm saying if you're going to do it you
better damn well go do it well and don't
half-ass it
and i went down the next day changed my
course schedule that my gpa got me into
film school
because i had a 3.82 i didn't have any
sort of art to show them
and i started off behind the camera and
then ended up
as i am now in front of the camera as
well but that book
that day that book finding me and me
feeling like it was
my secret and it came to me and no one
told me here you need to read this book
it'll be good for you hey you're
supposed to read this this is your
for school or even a recommendation it
was not wreck it found
me and i read that
book ever that did exactly what it said
morning noon and night
and i read i've read it three times now
that way but the first time
i didn't miss one reading of that i mean
and i had many a day
where i went out in the morning on a
saturday and
my day of whimsy took me to a place
where all of a sudden it was 10 o'clock
at night
and i was like an hour and a half from
my house
and the book was back at my house and
i'd be like hanging out partying and
going like oh geez
and i would stop eat something
get some coffee drink a bunch of water
wait till whatever
1 30 in the morning when i was time to
drive and i would drive
back to my place grab that book
and either read it and go to sleep in my
bed or drive back to where i was hanging
out
with the book and read it i didn't miss
one single read
for 10 straight months and that book is
the most instrumental piece of
literature and motivation i've ever read
for me in my life and now
you've produced green lights this book
which as as you've described it is not a
traditional memoir or an advice book but
rather a playbook
based on adventures in my life and i
want to hop to a particular portion of
this book which is also a scrapbook of
sorts
it's very multimedia in that respect
even though it's
in 2d in book format i want to ask you
about a note
and this will segue into the practice of
writing since you've kept
a diary for somewhere between 35 40
years at this point i believe
there's a note towards the end of green
lights
from 9192
yeah so 10 goals in life this blew my
mind
so i want to read these 10 and then i
want you to kind of place us
in your life when you wrote these 10 and
then i
i want to zoom in on a few of them but
let me just read these
10 first so 10 goals in life this is
1992.
one become a father two find and keep
the woman for me
three keep my relationship with god four
chase my best self
five be an egotistical utilitarian
that's gonna be my first follow-up
question
six take more risks seven stay close to
mom and family
eight win an oscar for best actor nine
look back and enjoy the view
ten just keep living
where were you and when were you when
you
wrote these 10 goals
[Applause]
i was in a top bunk
in the delta tall delta house i believe
my roommate was monty wills
i'm still friends with today from
montgomery alabama
i was the top bunk i think i just
probably it was the end it was the end
of the night it was about 9 30 i was
just getting nestling in for
for a good night's sleep so i just
started
what was the food date 93 what was the
month in the the month of the day
that was september 1st 1992 first okay
yes so i just
done i just finished days confused
that's right yes two day two days after
finishing
yeah i just finished it
a job a summer hobby a thing that
there were three lines written in a
script
that i got cast in because i went to the
right bar at the right time met the
right guy
redfor richard linklater said come on
and started throwing me in scenes so
three lines turned into three weeks work
i loved it was getting paid 320
a day people were telling me i was good
at it and i was running around going
like is this legal
it's so fun and i finish it
my father had just passed away like two
weeks earlier yeah august 17th
of that year so i just finished
a job that was a hobby that now that
became a career
i had just finished that think about if
you do the math i didn't think about
till now i just finished that agma dino
ten months of reading that book
while my father had just passed away
i was just going through what that meant
to me and what that what i felt like
that should mean to me
and that's where the just keep living
comes from to keep his spirit alive even
though he's physically not here
keep things alive that he taught me that
it could keep me incentivized throughout
my life even though i couldn't rely on
him personally being here to back me up
with them
and so i remember writing those goals
down
and the thing is that you know when you
start off this conversation going i
don't know what your what your
your agitator adverb was about but i i
found that
just less than a year ago in my diaries
and i'd never
looked at it or remembered that i had
written it
since the day i did that date
on that list i never looked at that list
again
i wrote it that night and forgot about
it
or at least i thought i forgot about it
i didn't and that's the wild part
because somewhere subconsciously i
obviously did
remember it because so far i've
accomplished those goals and there's
some very specific ones on there
that i'm like what you know
i always thought even the acting part
win an oscar for best actor
this is a time i just finished days
confused i didn't know i was gonna end
up being an actor
i still thought didn't have the courage
to even think i could pursue it as a
career i at that time i thought it might
just be a hobby
i had a hobby for a summer but obviously
when i look back i'm like oh you did
want to be
you did want to be an actor and you
wanted to be a damn good one
so i could admit it on my journal page
but i couldn't admit it to myself how i
couldn't even admit it in my dreams
but i could admit it on my journal pages
so that's where i was those are so those
are
three big things going on in my life and
i'd say the most you know the biggest
shape-shifter was father moving on and
uh but that
with finishing days and with finishing
um the greatest salesman
that's when i wrote that that's quite a
venn diagram as far as
a snapshot in time goes with those three
sort of momentous changes those
transitions
if we zoom in on number five be an
egotistical utilitarian
do you recall what you meant when you
wrote that 100
i'd written a uh i later that next year
maybe it was my junior year i wrote a uh
a law of a paper an essay and john wayne
goes west
the egotistical utilitarian and i guess
it was me
writing a story about a fictional
character that i guess was based on
me going west to hollywood but the
egotistical utilitarian i'm always like
boy that's it that's what the real
prophets are
that's what jesus was up to making
decisions that's that's the honey hole
of
when we are really can succeed or have
satisfaction or live
life the most truest where the decisions
we make for the eye
for ourselves the selfish decisions
are actually what's best for the most
amount of people utilitarian
are the eye where the eye meets the we
where the selfish is the selfless
where what i need is what i want
and what i want is the ego what i need
is the utilitarian
what i want is freedom what i need is
the responsibility and the interplay of
those things
what i is the ego and utilitarian is the
objective utilitarian we um
that i was already starting to work and
a lot of that these thematics are
through the book because they're
inherently how i
see life and have for a long time but
that was uh i was like oh that's the
ultimate human
the egotistical utilitarian where the
decision one makes for themselves most
selfishly
happened to be the most selfless
decisions as well at the same time
and where those two overlap and are one
that's the ultimate human that was a
pursuit that was my belief that
and why take more risks we might come
back to egotistical utilitarianism
why take more risks did you feel like at
the time you weren't taking enough risks
was it something you had learned about
risks
from your parents or other people why
take more risks
i think i was at that time seeing
risks that i'd take really pay off the
risk
to in the bar at the top of the hyatt
that night to go down and introduce
myself to don phillips who ended up
being the casting director for days
confused
who four hours later at the end of the
night after we got kicked out of the bar
says hey you ever done any acting
you might be right for this part taking
that
the the risk to go and read for that
part the risk
for richard linklater to say there's
nothing you're not supposed to be in
this scene you're not written in this
scene but do you think waterson would be
in it the risk for me to go
oh yeah and just hop in the middle of
the scene
and improvise and play those risks were
paying off
i was also beginning to feel you know
the risk that i took
reading that damn book the greatest
salesman it's the first book i've ever
read cover to cover and it's a thin
paperback
mind you it takes 10 months to read but
that was a risk for me and i was feeling
very confident with who i was
i was also thrown upside down by
my dad moving on now i don't know you
know if you've lost a parent
but look is the son losing a dad you
want to talk about forced into identity
you know my dad being this
sort of crutch just because he was alive
and above government and above
law was now gone i had no crutch i had
no safety net all of a sudden
i remember this very clearly this coming
to me and decided to just keep living
with keeping his spirit alive i remember
one of the first lessons of him moving
on was i was and i carved this in a tree
i remember carving this deeply in a tree
for about three hours one night
less impressed more involved
and that leans into taking more risk
because i was like after dad moved on i
was like oh
all of these mortal things in life that
i
have a reverence for even this point of
just finishing acting and maybe having
to
do you know dreams of fame wow
all these things that i revered that
were mortal
lowered down to eye level and at the
same time
everything that i noticed that i was
condescending or looking down upon or
slumping my nose at are going ah that's
that's crap or oh they're they're no
good
i was like they raised up to eye level
and i remember going oh the world is
flat
your dad's moved on you better look the
world in the eye and by seeing the world
flat i saw further i saw wider
i saw more clearly i had more courage i
lost reverence for mortal things that i
had reverence for i still respected them
but i lost
reverence for them so that gave me
courage and i
lost this sort of uh snub-nosed look at
things that i thought were beneath me
and i empowered them and they raised up
to eye level so all of a sudden
you know that was a version where the i
met the wii for me that was a version
where what i looked up to maybe too much
met
what i was looking down on and it was
right in front of me
and that was how i was also
taking more risk i i i lost a lot of
fear i
i still had fear but i gained a lot of
courage to go meet my fears
and i didn't give enough credence to
things that i probably shouldn't fear
or have too much reverence for because
they were mortal and i was like what's
that that's you know
reverence for fame or not taking a
chance to go get what you want that's a
mortal fear that's like putting a limit
on yourself makani why would you do that
i even called it a sin at that time not
to take certain risk
and would feel guilty if i didn't and
feel like i didn't do my due diligence i
didn't i didn't
meet my quote that day in god
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know if you missed
10 of the best performing days after the
2008 crisis you would have missed out on
50 percent five zero percent of your
returns
don't miss out on the best days in the
market stay invested
in a long-term automated investment
portfolio wealthfront
pioneered the automated investing
movement sometimes referred to as robo
advising
and they currently oversee 20 billion
dollars of assets for their clients
wealthfront can help you diversify your
portfolio minimize fees and lower your
taxes
takes about three minutes to sign up and
then wealthfront will build you a
globally diversified portfolio of etfs
based on your
risk appetite and manage it for you at
an incredibly low cost
wealthfront software constantly monitors
your portfolio day in and day out so you
don't have to
they look for opportunities to rebalance
and tax loss harvest to lower the amount
of taxes you pay on your investment
gains
their newest service is called autopilot
and it can monitor any checking account
for excess cash to move into savings or
an investment account
they've really thought of a ton they've
checked a lot of boxes
smart investing should not feel like a
roller coaster ride
let the professionals do the work for
you go to wealthfront.com
tim and open a wealthfront investment
account today and you'll get your first
five thousand dollars managed for free
for life that's wealthfront.comtim
wealthfront will automate your
investments for the long term and you
can get started today at wealthfront.com
tim
why did you start using a diary or what
has that helped you to do or given you
over your decades
of doing it because i've spoken to many
people
on this podcast who journal often they
have different forms of journaling
including a name we talked about very
briefly before recording josh waitzkin
very different approaches a very
different reasons what is it that you've
gotten from having a diary and maybe
it's changed over time yeah
it's it's evolved i mean my diary
started off like i think most people's
diaries do you write things down when
you're
not in a good place or you're lost and
and
you know my early diary entries were the
the why what where when house you know
the
the existential questions of what is
going on does it matter who am i oh my
god this [ __ ] so my girlfriend broke up
with me i lost it
started off at that so i noticed that i
started writing down when i was in
times of distress or disillusion and
then
i started to say well wait a minute
you gotta just like that agmandino book
by hooker by crook you read it three
times a day
i was like well we're gonna write my
diary every day mcconaughey and so when
do i when do when do most of us
including me
not write in our diary when things are
going great oh i got it figured out
i'm not going to need to take time to go
be introspective and write down my
thoughts everything
everything's a green light it's great
well
no i said hang on a second we're gonna
spend our life a diary
the original use of a diary is to
dissect failure
or or disillusion i think there's some
prudence and let's dissect success let's
dissect what's going on when things are
going well
that's that's right in this diary when
you feel like
everything's clear and you feel strong
and confident and significant
and you feel like yourself so i started
writing in my diary when things were
going well
and then started to map out certain
things about
found that what that did is when i would
get in a proverbial rut later
i could go back to that diary and look
at what was i
writing what was i doing when i felt
like everything was lickety-split and i
had
everything handled and i found
consistencies
i found it from what i was eating to who
i was hanging out with
how much sleep i was getting to beauties
in the world that i was noticing
and really were affecting me how i
approached people how i was approaching
the day how i was approaching conflict i
was approaching
and taking in things that work success
and i found consistencies and
so sometimes going back in those diaries
reading
what i was writing when things were
going well would help get me out of a
rut later on in life
when i wasn't doing so well and i
remember this early on in college it's a
reason
that uh my buddy as i mentioned earlier
rob milner said
you should go into storytelling business
is i was writing short stories but i was
also writing things down
idiosyncrasies of myself i was really
going to get to know myself
i would always when i'd be in a movie
theater i always laughed
i thought the funniest jokes i'd laugh
i'd be the only one laughing in the
theater and i never thought
the stuff that everybody laughed that
was funny the collective laugh i never
even giggled that i was like i don't
want them very funny
but i lied house i was like and no one
else would laugh and i was like no one
else thinks that's funny
i'd say that in the theater i found that
i cried at things
that other people didn't cry at like
i've never really cried at death
i weep at birth beginnings always have
made me cry more than
proverbial ends so i started writing
these things down
and at first was feeling like are you
weird kind of hey is this odd is this is
this okay
can you be this kind of a person and got
the confidence to go yes you can
it's okay but let's write down those
things let's write down what makes you
laugh what makes you happiest
what makes you sad what makes you angry
and
don't worry if it's the collective
choice of
of the majority just what what does it
mean to you
and write those things down and so that
led to
character i believe it led to my own
character it led to me
being able to maybe go play different
characters to understand
then empathize with different people and
have different people have different
things that turn them on and turn them
off at different times
why green lights what is the
concept or the intent behind
using that word what does it represent
for you
well one it's just a pretty cool title
you know i mean i wouldn't get stuck you
know
i mean i you know i went through the uh
the very earnest
but not very good student independent
films of a freshman or sophomore
student like i was you know where you're
trying to work out something as
extensive or you want to sound really
cool like
you know i went through forced winters
you know and i mean because
i have in the book what i would call a
lot of forced winters mind you i call
this coveted timer and right now a
forced
winter um i had a you know my most
creative times came in my forced winters
of life my year in australia are broad
on my own
but forest winter is kind of a double
negative i mean who wants to go open a
book called forced winners you know what
i mean so
grief like much more affirmative and
and and i love verbs i love words that
that are verbs verb is the holy word as
i'm sure you know and that it has
affirmation it is
it's it's alive and so green lights i
noticed became a theme to the book
because
the metaphor of the yellow and the red
lights that we have in our life
whatever those hard times are i noticed
in
going through my diaries of 36 years
that things that were
definite red lights in my life hard
times yellow lights in my life
interruptions interventions things that
stopped my flow and gotten my way
that at some point either sometimes
immediately
or decades down the line
revealed their green light assets in my
life
i would argue my dad's passing was a
green light
now his dying was a
literal red light but as i mentioned
earlier
i would not be the man i am right now if
he did not move on
i would have stayed lazy i would have
stayed more impressed
and less involved i would have not put
myself to task and held myself and
called myself to arms to man up and be
more honest with myself and look at the
world more honestly and have more
courage if he had not passed on
because i would have had him as a crutch
i would have had this sort of
subconscious reliance that oh if i
really get in a bond i still got dad i
still got pop
he's my safety net so his passing
revealed green lights
for me so green lights became a theme
and it became i noticed that
sometimes it's about persisting through
something enduring something
other times it's about pivoting wait a
minute i'm banging my head on the wall
here i'm
basically living out the definition of
insanity trying to
change something the same way over and
over again and it's not changing
so i need to reapproach this i need to
back up and and maybe dance around the
situation dance around the problem to
get what i want and then other times i
notice it's just you raise the white
flag and go you know what
i'm fighting for the wrong thing here
this is going against my grain this is
not really what i
what i want and need so i'm going to
live to fight another day and go find
something else
to challenge to overcome and so all in
those
are methods in which i've been able to
find green lights
um sometimes i've gotten green lights i
think we all do by just sheer straight
ass denial
i mean i write that line in that great
lesson it's
wisdom i heard from a very old man one
time you know i've had many crisis
i've had thousands of crisis in my life
hell most of them never happened i mean
that partially you get
by just denying that there is a crisis
not being foolish with it but some
things i've just said like i'm not even
going to give that crisis credit
therefore it doesn't exist that dart
can't stick to me if you throw it at me
if i don't give it
if i don't even give credit that it's a
dart you know what i mean
so so that's that's the
green lights i mean ultimately i believe
that in the rear view mirror of our life
every red and yellow light will turn
green
and that may not even be in this life
tim
i think a lot of people it happens for
people in this life tomorrow
next week next month next year 10 years
from now on our death bed
but i if it doesn't happen then i think
it can happen
in the next life for our kids or for our
kids kids our grandkids it's a lesson
maybe realized
three five ten generations from now
it may become a green light for some
hardship that we go through
in this life now well there are a
million directions we can go
i have eight options
that'll make sense yeah
that's well you know that would make
sense as soon as you hear where i'm
going with it so there are a number of
themes
that emerge in this book which which i
take to be
as you've mentioned a playbook of sorts
and helping you to
either change your reality or change how
you see that reality
in the service of engineering or
recognizing
green lights of different types right
and the eight themes
that i've written down here i'm going to
let you take dealer's choice on see
i'd like to pick one and explore so one
outlaw logic two find your frequency
three dirt roads and autobahns
four i like the sound of this one the
art of running downhill
five turn the page six the arrow doesn't
seek the target the target seeks the
arrow
seven be brave comma take the hill eight
live your legacy now where should we go
first good sir oh geez these are fun
look let's start i want to get to order
running downhill because that one i know
tickled you so maybe we should just
we can start with that one and we should
we should maybe hit dirt roads as well
dirt roads and auto bonds
let's do it let's do dirt roads and auto
bunch real quick because it's it's
it's simple it's a simple flip on the i
think it's robert frost you know the
road less taken has made all the
difference
yeah is that robert frost you know i'm
sure that my listeners
or my team will tell us if it's not
forgive the male prop but you know the
quote
um the road less the road less traveled
has made all the difference right
well that always has been like take the
dirt road
don't go where the majority goes you
know and i remember
in film school i was the frat boy
button-down shirt
jeans and boots hand shaker non-cynical
love the sunshine and i was in a
class with a bunch of all the filming it
was the gothic group they all wore black
t-shirts they
they stayed in the shadows they wore
their shades they kind of huddled in the
back
i remember one of our classes was one of
the things was hey everyone go see a
movie this weekend come back monday talk
about your movie
i'd come back and talk about you know
die hard
and soon as i started talking about what
i liked about it it'd be like ah
stuff [ __ ] maths corporate sellout crap
and i'd be like oh geez and i remember
they you know they'd all gone to the
eisenstein revival that weekend and
we talk about that and i remember being
really intimidated going like
wow they're artists
i'm not yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i gotta i gotta i gotta untuck
my shirt here a little bit i got i gotta
i gotta quit going outside and i gotta
not appreciate the sunshine i gotta
i gotta quit singing out loud i gotta i
gotta i gotta i gotta get more
and leshi in here you know and
and just as i was going through that
mental meditation on myself
i remember coming back again another
week after a weekend we've seen a movie
and i'd gone to the multiplex again and
seen a popular movie and brought it up
and of course the cat calls from all the
the other filmmakers in the class
all them black huddled up so i'm going
ah that's corporate [ __ ] uh
nobody sees that that's a sellout and i
remember instead of backing down this
time i went i went wait a minute
did you see how do you know it's
corporate [ __ ] how do you know it is
what makes you say that
and they all stopped and kind of started
looking at each other and
started stuttering and then finally one
of them goes
well i mean we didn't see it i mean we
don't know but i mean we just you know
and i went ah
[ __ ] you man
i said after this time i thought y'all
been seeing it and you got this you
haven't even gone to see it
so that was where it hit me i was like
oh
there i was thinking that the road less
taken
you know sometimes a dirt road my dirt
road
was the autobahn of the multiplex
you know my my their their their dirt
road you know would have been
would have would have been the same they
needed to go see that go see
a popular studio movie before just
calling it off as nothing
sometimes you know if there were two and
i've had in my life someone
say someone's an agoraphobic their dirt
road
is getting out you know someone who's a
bit of a hermit or
or socially uncomfortable their dirt
road is being an extrovert
go out engage practice it so
it's a flip on that that sometimes it's
you know the road less taken can be a
dirt road yes
anytime a path less taken and other
times for some people some of us in our
times in our life it's an auto bond
and sometimes you know i've used to be
so extroverted
i never would spend time with myself
reading a book or doing introspection
well that was a dirt road for me to take
some introspection now
shoot sometimes i love being
introspective so much i like being in my
dark room writing
more than i like engaging with people
well
my dirt road sometimes now is like put
the pin down mcconaughey get your ass
out in the world and go engage
in the daylight and get out there so it
changes for us and sometimes the dirt
road sometimes
is an autobahn and it is robert frost i
can connect
thank you robert yeah the other one that
tickled you on the way down is the art
of running downhill
now may i may i actually ask a follow-up
to the dirt roads
and autobahn so it seems like if i'm
hearing you correctly
and understanding that it is
a proactive approach to facing
the discomforts that you may have
or the hesitation that you may need to
face
at least in part it seems like that is
part of the lesson
and the person who introduced us ryan
holiday
had encouraged me to ask you about
stoicism which
seems to in some respect tie into that
since many
stoics at least historically those
people we've read about would
take periods of time to do the things
that would lead them to discomfort
do you have any just uh just as a side
avenue here
do you do you have any perspectives on
on stoicism i mean i think i do but
you're gonna i'm probably gonna botch
this up because i
don't exactly know the vernacular of the
stoics near as well as you and ryan do
i will say this you know his other book
obstacles that is the way
and i i touch on this in my book a lot
in my own way look
the need for resistance the need
to choose the right harder
challenge the need to choose a harder
decision for the right reasons
the need to choose the obstacles for
which to overcome
or at least attempt to overcome is very
very wise engagement the need as i talk
about in my book quite a few times
to get away and go off on your own and
be stuck with yourself even if it's the
worst [ __ ] company you've ever had
that is a good thing to do there is a
good
valuable penance there are green lights
in that
forcing your red light sid forcing
yourself into the red light of being
stuck
with the only person you can't get rid
of even though you hate him
and yes i use that word and i've had
those times
and in those times of groveling and
discomfort and i can't sleep
and i'm throwing up and i can't get the
monkeys off my back and i got through
guilt and oh my god i'm lost but i've
got nowhere to go
i got no one to reach out to i don't
have a phone i have a car i ain't got a
friend
well going through that those sleepless
nights and going
when is this going to end and going
through
well all right mcconaughey
what are we going to forgive and what
are we going to say
enough's a [ __ ] nuff and we're
changing that in our lives and let's
shake hands on this because you're the
only son of a [ __ ] i can't get rid of
[Laughter]
well let's if you don't mind i want to
take it and this is just the nature of
my
perhaps unfocused perhaps non-linear
mind we're going to come back to the art
of running downhill i will not forget
but you're talking about you were
talking about the paying the penance
of spending time with yourself the
red light of solitude that can create
green lights
why did you write this book as i
understand it or you went away to the
desert
by yourself for 52 days without
electricity is this true
the first 12 days were no electricity
the other 40
were limited electricity in places but
it was five different trips i took
to to solitary confinement each time so
i spread them out i had to come home and
take care of some
some honeydews and check in with the
family make sure everything was running
good at the homestead before my wife set
me off again and said get out of here
and don't come back until you got
something
so solitude seems to be also a through
line at least a practice
of sorts yeah any other commentary on
on solitude and in those moments when
you're spending time with yourself
which i guess is all the time but i want
to know
do you have in your inner monologue a
difference between when you say
your last name to yourself and your
first name or do you ever use your first
name when you're talking to yourself i
know you know a good question
well let me tell you what the best the
the best thing for mike tyson the future
for
is what mike tyson wants to is yeah i
i've thought about that it's a fun thing
to
talk about to yourself in the third
person but when you're in a socratic
dialogue you got to give your other self
your name
and i guess i'll tell my mcconaughey um
[Music]
and you know these dialogues let's talk
about those you know this
that old adage oh don't talk to yourself
what
[ __ ] do talk to yourself
what i think we need to remember to do
is when we're asking ourselves these
questions
just make sure we answer if all we're
doing is asking ourselves questions but
never coming up with an
answer well that can lead to some very
imbalanced insanity at times that's a
really
really
important point i just want to pause to
let that sink in for people
so please continue but that is so so
important just looking back at my
depressive periods that i've experienced
it's when i'm asking a lot of questions
and not actually taking the time to sit
down
and write down the answers or think
about answers yeah
or force yourself to remain in the
discomfort of the questions
instead of going i i give
where's the bottle or where's you know
where's some attention
or or or you know where's where's
something some entertainment where's the
tv
you know what i mean so i can get my
mind off of it don't a
situation don't abort the times when we
got the questions
now mind you you know i've had to
you know in some of those times when i'm
going off and i know it's going to be a
we're going to i'm going to don't know
how long it's going to be till i come
out the other side
i'm about to take a helmet and a chin
strap and a mouth guard and put padding
on the walls
[Music]
you know because i knew it was going to
be a wrestling match with the me and the
me
um so and i've kept the floor before i
go it's nice when you go off to do these
things
to go let's check the floor make sure
there's no broken glass where let's
remove the sharp objects
because this is gonna get four
dimensional and uh
you know so but to stick in there with
it
and to go through the withdrawal of the
not knowing
to go through the draw of the questions
um and i don't mean withdrawal from a
from a substance go through withdrawal
of
not getting along with yourself is i
mean a great thing to do
and it's hard for a reason but again
that goes back to what you said
it stay there till you answer it wait
till you get an answer wait till you
either figure out what you're forgiving
and figure out what you're gonna you
what you had enough of what you're like
no no i'm not putting up with that part
of myself anymore we're not going to
keep being a repeat repeat offender on
that
mcconnell hey or tim you know what i
mean and and we're going to change
that and then all of a sudden there
comes some grace you come out the other
side like
okay now i'm stuck with my buddy the one
i can't get rid of if we're going to do
this at least we shook hands and
you're not perfect but we're moving
forward and we've evolved a little bit
because of this time that we forced
to spend with ourselves yeah to answer
those
or stick with it or
you know to evolve the conversation
from where it was when you first went
into solitude
at least you know so i'm a fan of people
talking themselves and
say it just remember to answer yourself
you know
you know but don't just have it in one
way it's not a socratic dialogue unless
you can
respond
the art of running downhill what is the
art of running downhill
okay
so i get successful
i got
major fame very quickly after a time to
kill came out
with the film i did in 96 and i mean
from the friday
friday afternoon before it came out to
the monday
after the weekend it came out my whole
world was
inverted the world all of a sudden was
one big mirror
i never meet strangers since that day
it was inverted i mean that friday
afternoon before time to kill comes out
there's 100 scripts out there i want to
do
i want to do all are you kidding me i'll
do any of them
well 99 no you can't one of them yes you
can
well in a matter of two days after that
film opened that weekend and did well
that hundred scripts it was yes you can
do 99
one no so i was like whoa two days ago i
would have done any of these
and could only do one and now
it's only two days later but you're
telling me i can do 99 of them
help me discernment discrimination can i
make a choice who am i
geez what i want to do there's only 24
hours in the days last i checked
i need more um so i was a little you
know
imbalanced overwhelmed didn't have my
feet
my soul on the ground and there were
times that and i also
remember that same lawyer i talked about
the ola mink story jerry harris
i remember him telling me he reached out
i hadn't talked to him for years he read
tap and he goes
hey matthew you're from a small town
you've already texted you know you came
through longview texas now you went out
there now a famous hollywood star and
you got all these things he goes
make sure you don't suffer too much from
the non-deserving complex
that happens with some people that get
real successful from sort of humble
beginnings
and it made a lot of sense to me because
i was noticing
that you know in the name of obstacles
being the way i was creating obstacles
for myself some of them very unnecessary
meaning here's my life i'm successful
i'm rolling
i am catching green lights i am going
i'm rolling downhill
i very less than gracefully handled
some of my success i would become
belligerent at times i didn't become
belligerent trying to pre you know
they always say this don't you know it's
okay to have a point to prove just don't
always be trying to prove a point
many times where i would try to prove a
point you know what i mean
and it was my own insecurity it was my
own self trying to find some balance in
this
it was me i was seeing the mendacities
of of all these people
in hollywood all of a sudden saying i
love you and i'm like man i've said that
to four people in my life
and everyone says it out here ah they're
they're full of [ __ ]
it was i was taking things personally
even
and sort of sabotaging some of the
uh red carpet whining caviar that was
being handed to me
you know what i mean uh and i was
slipping to some of my more banal self
at times and doing a proverbial face
plant
meaning i'm running downhill and since
this is all easy street
i need resistance so i think i'm gonna
trip myself
and face plant and break my right into
the concrete so i can break my nose so i
can go ah
there i go now i'm earning it now i feel
it
now i've earned it now i deserve it well
that can be a little foolish there's an
art to going downhill and so what i
noticed was
oh hard times are going to come it's
going to get dry you're not going to be
able to do whatever script you want to
do i've had birth times or
in a relationship we go through it
doesn't go well
or someone gets sick in the family a
real
uphill battle enters our life and so
the art of running downhill is about hey
enjoy it
when you're going downwind downhill
don't trip yourself
because that uphill's coming all right
it's going to be it's going to come
whether you want it to or not
so don't trip yourself in face plant
right now because you're going to have
to work your ass off here very shortly
anyway let's talk about perhaps an
uphill perhaps a pause perhaps something
else
which i'd love for you to comment on
which did come later
and that was a decision which i'd love
to
explore to say no to
quite a lot of opportunities for a
period of time it seems like at one
point you were very
successful you became very famous like
you said practically overnight
you're being offered opportunities you
you couldn't have imagined
a week prior and you have a string of
successes
and then you realize well wait a minute
here i might be getting
painted into a corner and you start to
say no
you start to turn down say action film
opportunities with big paychecks
things like that was that hard to do
did other people say that you were doing
the right thing and
encourage you could you walk us through
and just tell a story about that
experience
love to so this is around i don't
remember the year i'm guessing it's
around 12 13 years ago
i was rolling with the romantic comedies
i had taken the baton
from hugh grant and was the wrong the
the the male lead rom-com go-to guy
rom-coms are mid-level budgets 30-35
million
they offer a good front-end paycheck to
me they go make 60 million
i mean if the studios don't have to
overspend and spend
hundreds of millions of dollars to make
them you get a good female and a male
lead that have good chemistry
people love to go escape to them myron
comps are doing well they were my bank
they were what hollywood banked on me to
be in at the same time
i'm living in malibu learning to surf
got my shirt off
and the paparazzi your discovery channel
is like almost documenting this and i'm
like
damn right document it this is the life
i'm living i love it i worked and earned
to get this life
and those romantic comedies that i get
paid so handsomely for actually pay the
rent at the house
on the beach that i live in in front of
this water that i'm surfing in
so i was full-on shaking hands with gun
yes
at the same time i did notice
that any other dramas i wanted to do
or even the way people sort of when i
said don't meet strangers anymore
even when this sort of people thought of
me or approached me or
talked to me or about me there was no
consideration it was it was it was like
he's the shirt that's rom-com guy and i
was like yeah i am
and i'm but there only i could answer
that second question
of and i'm like only i could continue
that that that sentence no one else
could
they were like hollywood for sure was
like no nothing else and so any dramas i
wanted to do
or other pictures no one wanted to make
them with me
and i remember i just we just had uh
uh levi camille and i just had our first
son and
my life was so vital
man i just had a newborn i've met the
woman that i love and want to spend the
rest of my life
with i'm laughing harder i'm crying
harder i'm
happier than ever life is very
vital and i'm in it my real life is
but my work feels like
yeah yeah i could do that tomorrow
morning just give me the script tonight
let me look at i could do it tomorrow it
wasn't really challenging me
and the rom-coms weren't challenging me
and my lifestyle was
one big green light and you know too
many
it's all green lights it's all sugar and
candy we'll
we can that'll make tyrants out of
anybody so i was saying oh i really want
my
i wish my work could i remember saying
this at least i remember looking in the
mirror actually
okay mcconaughey so if your life is more
vital and true
to who you are than your work well if
it's got to be one of the other
that's a good thing because i know a lot
of people that their work is more vital
than their life so i said that's a good
thing
i said but geez could i just get some
work that might challenge the vitality
of my life and the man i am in it
where i can get some work where i can be
more me in it
well those roles were not being offered
to me
nothing nope not a chance we won't no
studio will bank you in this drama role
or this other role you want i had
control of dallas buyers club at that
time but no one wanted to make it for me
nor would anyone finance it
so i decided that if i couldn't do
what i wanted to do and what i wanted to
do was not being offered to me
it would be prudent for me to just stop
doing what i had been doing
and what was in the pipeline continually
coming to me which were the
romantic comedies i called my money
manager
said all right look i'm gonna stop doing
the only work i'm getting offered and i
don't know how long
it's going to be till i work again how
am i doing with my money he says you've
invested well conservatively you're fine
you can take time off i remember calling
my agent jim toth
at ca jim i don't want to do romantic
comedy anymore i remember this
conversation he goes great and i go wait
what do you mean great he goes great i
go
how do you say that so quick what are
you going to say monday morning when you
go into your superiors in the office and
say mcconaughey's not doing romantic
comedies
and mcconaughey's been bringing a nice
chunk of 10 commission into you guys
with these romantic comedies for years
now
and he said the coolest thing to me
because i don't work for them i work for
you
that's a that's a good line to the line
right so
and then it was i went to camilla my
wife and
i had been you know i'd shed quite a few
tears with her going through this
you know am i am i feeling fraudulent in
my work
uh do i feel a lack of significance in
my work do i feel like
you know uh is it okay to be feeling you
know this i mean like i said remember
i'm do as we said earlier i'm
i'm connor going running downhill why
would you sabotage
not doing the work you're getting
offered but you can get paid so
handsomely to do it
but she understood that i that my soul
was shaken and needed some recalibration
and that
the work i was doing wasn't the true
sort of expression
of who i was in my life and i was i told
her i said well i want to get find
hold up for some work that can challenge
the vitality of the life that i'm living
with you and our son levi
and she repeated the lines to me she
goes okay you're going to get wobbly
i've been around you you got to work
matthew and you love to accomplish
you're going to get wobbly
you might start you know reaching for a
little sip of something to drink earlier
in the day too and i'm like yeah yeah
and she's like she goes
days are going to be longer we don't
know how long this will last how long
we'll be in this we she called it a
desert
how long this will be a desert she goes
but if we're going to do this if you're
going to do this
we're not going to half-ass it she
repeated my dad's line to me
and i went yes ma'am gave her a hug put
some tears on her shoulder and we said
starting today no more rom comes well
rom-com offers came in to my agent for
about the next six months but nothing
but rom-com offers
and i didn't even unless it was a major
offer
yeah well i just said no and they just
stopped at my
agent's desk jim talk no and then one of
them came through
that was like a gargantuan offer for it
and
my agent said it's a pretty damn good
script too
and so i said we'll send it out let me
read it
and i remember this the offer was like
for
eight million dollars and the script was
pretty good
and but it was still kind of a rom-com
and i remember reading it and going
no thank you i remember feeling sort of
emboldened and strengthened by saying no
thank you
great sticking to my guns no rom-coms
six months into this drought nope not
cave it in now don't have fasting
mcconaughey
so they come back with a 10 million
dollar offer no thank you
they come back with a 12.5 million
dollars
now i go dot dot ellipses allergies
[Music]
no thank you now they come back with a
15
million offer wow you know what
let me have another reread of that
script
and i reread that and you know what
at 15 million dollars the same script
that i've been offered for eight million
knowledge the 15 million dollar offer
script which was the same exact
words as the eight million dollar offer
script the 50 million dollar scoop was
better it was funnier
it had possibilities it had angles i had
ideas i could make this work you know i
mean this could work
no i'm imagining at this point jim is
like man this saying no thing is really
working out
he's in and he's over there teetering
like
i know what we said you know but 50
million dollars and it's not like it's a
pretty good script
i know it's rom-com it's pretty good
script but i
said uh no no thank you
well that got the signal across
hollywood that
mcconaughey was taking a serious
sabbatical and
so don't even send him a rom-com it got
around
so that was kind of the crucible then i
mean that was like the crux move
in a sense in a way that was that was a
yeah i called an audible six months in
and i had them thinking i might
cave i might just be posturing and come
on back mcconnell hey we love you and i
said
no and when they had pumped the money
offer up so much and people knew in the
industry what that offer was
it became very clear oh oh [ __ ]
okay mcconnell i don't know what he's
doing but
he ain't doing this stuff he's not doing
any more rom-coms
and it became clear so for the next
true 12 14 months
nothing came in nada zilch
not an offer for anything i mean i'd
check talk to my agent every couple of
weeks it'd just be like nothing came in
nothing
so now we're 20 months into this desert
period um i do have my son to raise
which
you know being a father has always been
the most important thing to me so that
that's got my compass at least directed
in a place that i
i go just trust in this if it has
something to do with
raising your son and being here on the
land with your family
that even if you start to wander just
trust that that's always going to be
in the asset section mcconaughey you
can't go wrong with that
so i stuck to that and um
i was now fine with not doing any work i
didn't know what i was going to be
i didn't know if i was going to change
my career if i was going to become a
teacher or coach or
go back to being a lawyer i didn't know
i didn't think so but
i was writing more i was talking about
forced winners i had put a forced winner
on myself
and i was um pretty content
i wasn't you know waking up every
morning going did an offer come in did
something new come in i was past that
and then all of a sudden 20 months in 20
21 months into this desert
i could start getting some offers that
are interesting things william freaking
killer joe
lee daniels paper boy jeff nichols wrote
mud for me
steven soderbergh called magic mike
richard linklater and i go do bernie
together
true detective comes around all of a
sudden
dallas buyers club no one still wants to
you know put a bunch of money up for a
1980s period drama about aids but all of
a sudden
mcconaughey all the directors were no
directors would do dallas buyers club
with me they wanted they wanted the
script they loved the script they didn't
want to do it with mcconaughey all of a
sudden
we find jean-marc fellow who one who
says no i i'd like to deal with
mcconaughey
so what happened was
that 22 launch or whatever that drought
that
desert i unbranded
i didn't rebrand i unbranded me being
away
me being in texas not being on a beach
getting pictures of me shirtless on a
beach not being in rom-coms
i was out of the world's view i was out
of the industry's view i was not in your
living room i was not in your theater
i was not in any of the places that the
world would become expectant to see me
and how to see me
where was i i was gone where is
mcconaughey
well you're gone long enough all of a
sudden i became a new
good idea
which i was not a new good idea at any
time earlier than that
at the end of that 20 month period and
then all of a sudden the things came to
me that i wanted to do and i remember
saying you know what
[ __ ] the bucks i'm going for the
experience if i read a role that shakes
me in my boots and
challenges the vitality that i feel in
my own real life and challenges me the
man i am in my own real life
that's what i'm going after and man they
came in come in and i looked at each
other
she had some more tears and she we said
let's get after it
and i just started hammering them the
family came with me everywhere i went
and just started laying down work that
really really turned me on so i want to
dig into a few follow-up questions here
see so your wife
probably with some sage foresight
although i'm guessing said you're going
to get wobbly days are going to seem
longer you might reach for that bottle a
little earlier than you would
yeah normally what were some of your
practices
or some of the inputs that helped you to
either
stave off getting wobbly or to recover
when you did get wobbly
good question look my family me my mom
my brothers
supported me they thought i was plumbing
crazy for you know turning down that 50
million
offer and sitting there going like what
are you doing they thought i really was
face planting while running while having
a downhill ramp to run down
they were like what who in their right
mind would
you're not working do you like that i
was like yeah that works easy i like it
and they're offering you what what the
hell is your problem but they knew
you know they knew that i was like you
know that i was a thinker they'd known
that's
as long before that that i took myself
you know in those circumstances
seriously and then i was doing some soul
searching and that and and they thought
they they were like that makes sense to
us but we get it little brother
you know you're all right good luck so
they did support me
i'll say this this this helped we had a
very
real crisis in the family with someone
in my family that
needed all of my attention and all of my
time
meaning one of those real red lights
that entered our life
a real crisis that a real uphill battle
entered which gave me a large sense of
purpose
necessary purpose like it's not it's one
of those unequivocal things you don't
question it's like if i had
gotten any job i wanted in hollywood of
a script to go act at that time even
then i wouldn't have done it during
going through this family crisis
this was paramount it was unequivocally
the thing
to take care of so as you probably know
or
the death of someone in a family or a
big fat real family crisis that that'll
sober you up and i don't mean soviet
from the bottle that'll sober you up
from missing
any sort of again the scripts at that
time
movies making movies that was a mortal
thing
dealing with this family crisis was an
immortal thing
so i became very involved with handling
this family crisis and that is where my
identity was
that coupled with my son's being
raised he's a brand new day for him
every single day
he's getting to know me how awesome is
this that i
get to have this time because i know
i'll go back and do some work somewhere
somehow later
and it's not going to i'm not going to
have this time so let's lean into the
assets of being forced here with your
son
you're building a home with the woman
you love
and you've got this family crisis that
you're dealing with which is bringing
you close to your
closer back even closer to your blood
family so
i was finding purpose in in all of that
and you know as it usually happens
as it does it was getting to the point
where well i don't care if any
anything comes in i'm not even thinking
about it if any work comes in
i don't really care of course that's
about the time that the work comes in
you've traveled a very unorthodox path
in many respects what are
some of the biggest misconceptions if
any what are common misconceptions about
you
that you hope or that you could clarify
either
right now or or through the pages of
this book
are there any are there any any
misconceptions positive or
positive or negative yeah i mean look
one misconception i think
which it used to concern me more so than
it does now
is that i mean kind of everyone a lot of
people think that i sort of like just
wake up in the morning and go roll out
of bed and
say all right where's my mark what are
we doing today
what's what's this scene about what's
life about what
what's responsibility here today what is
oh yeah okay yeah
a lot of people think i just wing it
and the truth is like i was telling you
earlier about me being a studier and
loving my ass
i am a preparer
i that's i know a lot of my success and
satisfaction have come from
being majorly prepared and when i'm
majorly prepared
i prepare so i can so it's not work
when i get in the game i prepare so
that's the work my work is pregame
when i'm in the game i am when i'm best
at being in the game i am that guy that
looks like i just woke up in the morning
and just
hey what's up to make it look easy
comes from the preparation so i daily
prepared now whether it's work or trying
to be the best man i can or be the best
husband
or the best father i'm constantly trying
to work on that
you know i have the saying with you know
and now you reading the story
my mom and dad had a very physical and
oftentimes
violent loud relationship
hence divorced twice married three times
me i remember the last time i raised my
voice
to my wife or kids because for me
if i even get to the point where i have
to raise my voice or i get
you know start to feel like i'm going to
snap i immediately my threshold goes to
whoa whoa
what did you not handle up to this point
mcconaughey
to let it get to this there's you left
some crumbs
somewhere in your position
as a husband a father or a man to get to
this point
so let's not stop let's go back
and deconstruct how we got to this point
even feel like this because you dropped
the ball somewhere along the way
to keep this feeling and i have a pretty
short threshold for that feeling of what
let me recalibrate let me let me let me
take some stock and how i got to this
point because i'm
feeling like i'm about to snap or feel
like i'm even going to raise my voice
so you know that's some recalibrations
that i
inherently and instinctually i don't
know if i say i practice them but
i just that's where my head and the head
and heart goes
is that anger it does it does i think
that you know one of the
sort of gestalt impressions of the book
which is i mean really really fun and
very delightful i mean
so congratulations on the book it's not
easy to do
and and the
the gestalt impression is that you take
introspection and
maybe this isn't the right way to phrase
it but you take introspection seriously
and you practiced a lot of introspection
so you've been able to take these
moments that otherwise might be
lost in the slipstream those moments of
success where things seem to be going
well
the the lows and you've trapped them
like flies in the amber
so that you can look at them later and
even look at them like a flip book so
you can see the trends that take you in
one direction or another and i
and then that is that is not common so i
i'd like to just ask
one or two more questions that's yeah
that that
i mean i'm trying to get what i think
we're all trying to get
which i actually and let's talk about i
do think it's common
that we all want more roi
yes on ourselves on ourselves
and is there any less boring or vital or
immediate entertaining and angering and
interesting subject than us on ourselves
to create i mean i'm trying to i know
i'll never do it
but i'm trying to find some themes
that support a science to being
satisfied
and and i think we can all uncover those
in our lives by our habits like i said
earlier
looking at your diaries when you're
writing your diary when you when things
are going well
dissect success as well as failure there
become certain themes that become like
oh
it's kind of reliable i have more
satisfaction i
am more me i get more what i want i am a
better man i'm a better woman when i am
acting and doing these things going to
these places
thinking this way eating this spending
time with these peoples thinking these
thoughts
there's a science to it i don't think
i'll ever get it
but man what it's an incredibly fun
perspective
maddening but what a riddle yeah to keep
trying to figure out
that will be never ending right it's
like keeping track of plays in the game
of life
right i mean it's yeah yeah i have to
have the ability to look back at it
so if you were to have a billboard
metaphorically speaking to get a message
a question an image
anything out to billions of people could
have paragraph could be a word
anything non-commercial what might you
put on that billboard
uh a great question and i and it's it's
one that when i
i'd like to say i think about all the
time because i do have a marketeering
mind
it'd be two words with a question mark
behind them
i value question mark
tim i i i don't know how to make
systemic change
i don't not that interested in politics
seems it doesn't seem like the right i
don't know category maybe for the kind
of leadership that i want to listen to
or in some way in some forms be myself
it seems to me that that uh the common
denominator or the
bipartisan non-denominational solid
stepping stones
for us to evolve as a species as a
nation and as individuals
is based in values the fundamental
principles that we can all agree on i
don't care what side of
politics you're on or what religion you
are but what do we value
what do we really value we all want to
be relevant
well let's ask relevant for what yeah
before we say i want to be relevant
let's let's let's
and what are those values that we can go
oh that's
yeah if i act that way if i'm kind in
that way if i'm accountable in that way
if i have a sense of humor in that way
how is that
a very selfish act because it's good for
me
good for my ego fills me up pays me back
gives me mailbox money gives me
greenwood in my future
but it also gives you mailbox money
gives you it gives other people it gives
others
residuals and our future's compounding
asset
and i think we just we we need to work
on or and have fun
understanding that that the things we do
today the choices we make
are compounding assets to what where we
go in the future and if we have
make more valuable choices and give more
respect to the competence of values our
own personal values
we're buying more roi we're creating
more green lights in the future for
ourselves and
others i value question mark
very important statement right there and
question
and i agree with you about the values
and the also for what
right the the relevant yeah what
it's such an important focusing modifier
to adjectives they get thrown around
very commonly
and yeah you know that there's another
line in there that i have it's based off
that jeans being pressed story
is when we can ask ourselves if we want
to
before we do that goes along with
yeah i want to be relevant what weight
relevant for what
you know what i mean it's it's just
because we can and maybe we're in
positive position of
influence where we get an option put in
front of us that we've never had before
you know like i said time to kill 99
scripts i couldn't do yesterday and now
today you're telling me i can do all of
them what
well let's be discerning and ask
ourselves
do i really want to do that i know it's
the first time i have the ability to or
the first time it's been laid in front
of me that
i have the option to do that and i'm
sure i'm happy about that but before i
do it let me ask myself wait do i really
want to
you know for me the story about having
my jeans pressed i was so damn happy i
had a housekeeper for the first time she
pressed my jeans i was like wow
and then i had a friend tell me well
that's great if you like your jeans
pressed and immediately i went oh [ __ ] i
don't like
and ask yourself if we want to before we
do and yes we seek relevance but let's
ask relevance for what
well matthew you are one hell of
a storyteller you're a fun guy to talk
to some at some point
maybe separately i'll ask you about what
they put in the groundwater in texas for
this
storytelling
because you mary carr i don't know what
it is uh but uh that's another
conversation for another day
your books official website is
greenlights.com very easy for people to
remember
on facebook you are matthew mcconaughey
instagram
official mcconaughey twitter mcconaughey
and i will include links to everything
in the show notes for people
at tim.blog podcast so they can find
everything that we've talked about
is there anything else that you would
like to say
share ask recommend
with those people listening before we
come to a close
sure this came from a conversation
richard linklater and i were having
some years ago and it came out of just a
verbal ping pong that we did but
what i think is we all should could use
right now
and i need to remind myself of it daily
especially in these times where look
it's tough in ways that
for ourselves that we understand
sometimes we don't understand but it's
tough in ways for
for everybody in ways that maybe even
they don't understand and we probably
don't
so everyone can use a little bit of
amnesty right now
and what i mean by that is this if
you're not sure
how to respond to a situation can you
just make sense of humor the default
emotion
can we just have a little more humor and
give each other a bit of a break right
now it's tough times let's be
for each other right now instead of
against each other and sense of humor
does not
it does not get rid of the truth does
not get rid of the problem does not get
rid of the challenge it actually reveals
it sometimes in the most truthful ways
where we can laugh to have some humor
through the tears and humors through the
pain
and not laugh at someone else's expense
laugh at our expense
all of our the human existence expense
man we're doing the best we can
and if we're not we're let's help
somebody try to
hear here well thank you so much matthew
this was uh this is an incredibly
enjoyable conversation
and super fun for me tim i really
enjoyed it and love to do it anytime
yeah yeah so i'd love to do a round two
sometime maybe uh maybe when we're
in in uh proximity in austin we can do a
20-foot social distance so tbd
but your first book green lights is so
unexpected
it is so fun it is a romp through your
mind a romp through
the turns and twists and learnings of
someone who's had an
unorthodox path and on top of that
documented so much for decades uh it's
it's a it's a rare combination so i
encourage people to check it out
and for everybody listening we'll have
notes to all things we've discussed in
the show notes 10.
podcast and until next time thank you
for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's
just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off
for the weekend so if you want to
receive that check it out
just go to four hourworkweek.com that's
fourhourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by magic spoon
magic spoon is a brand new cereal that i
eat just about every day that is
low carb high protein and zero sugar i
just ate a huge bowl of their cocoa
flavor
about an hour ago after a short workout
magic spoon cereal
has received a lot of attention since
launching last year
time magazine included it in their list
of best inventions of 2019
and forbes called it the future of
cereal it tastes just like your favorite
sugary cereal from childhood remember
that
but it's actually good for you each
serving has 11 grams of protein
3 grams of net carbs 0 grams of sugar
and only 110 calories it's also gluten
free grain free keto friendly soy free
and
gmo free all the things it's delicious
and i don't say that lightly because
most of this healthy
version of x stuff is not delicious but
these guys really nail it magic spoon
has nailed it it comes in your favorite
traditional
cereal flavors like cocoa frosted and
blueberry you can try them all by
grabbing a variety pack
at magicspoon.com tim or you can just
grab a box
or a bunch of boxes i'm going to order
some more today of
the cocoa which is my personal favorite
but there is a new
contender for favorite flavor because
they just
launched two limited edition flavors
honey nut and peanut butter which are
delicious i am a sucker for peanut
butter
and it is outstanding so i think coco
and peanut butter are my two
new favorite flavors and fun fact my
friends are
also obsessed with magic spoon one of
the podcasts
most popular guest dr peter tia
routinely crushes six to seven servings
at a time that's a lot
with no glycemic response he's looked at
this with a glucometer
he likes it so much he invested other
friends two
very fine gentlemen and also past
podcast guests kevin rose and ryan
holiday
also invested so check it out see what
the buzz is about go to magicspoon.com
tim and grab a variety pack or coco
which is my favorite or anything else
but
see what strikes your fancy why not try
a variety pack
and be sure to use code tim at checkout
my listeners
that's you get free shipping and a 100
happiness guarantee so if you're not a
fan if you don't love it they'll give
you a full refund no questions asked
again check it out magicspoon.com
forward slash
tim that's magic spoon dot com forward
slash tim
take a look this podcast episode is
brought to you by
helix sleep sleep is super important to
me in the last few years
i've come to conclude it is the end-all
be-all that all good things
good mood good performance with
everything seem to stem
from good sleep so i've tried a lot to
optimize and i've tried
pills and potions all sorts of different
mattresses
you name it and for the last few years
i've been sleeping on a helix
midnight luxe mattress i also have one
in the guest bedroom
and feedback from friends has always
been fantastic it's something that they
comment on
helix sleep has a quiz takes about two
minutes to complete that matches your
body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you with helix
there's a specific mattress for each and
every body
that is your body also your taste so
let's say you sleep on your side
in like a super soft bed no problem or
if you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress
that's as firm as a rock they've got a
mattress for you too helix was selected
as the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
magazine
wired apartment therapy and many others
just go to helixsleep.com
tim take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep
of your life they have a 10-year
warranty you get to try it out for
100 nights risk-free they'll even pick
it up from you if you don't love it and
now my dear listeners helix is offering
up to 200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows
at helixsleep.com tim
these are not cheap pillows either so
getting two for free
is an upgraded deal so that's up to 200
off and two free pillows at helix sleep
dot com
slash tim that's helix h e l i
x sleep dot com slash tim for up to 200
off so check it out one more time helix
h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
[Applause]
time
you